go go go go go go
come on baby come on
[Music]
dispatch i'm probably going to step it
up it's one
come on buddy
come on buddy hey
hey
get up
[Music]
[Music]
all right look
out doors are locked i can't get them
open
watch your head
can you start climbing up the block
can you climb out the back
climb out the back
come on
climb out the back
come on the back is open i need you to
climb out the back
climb out the back
come
i on my gun out i got the back cracked i
can't crack this come on climb out the
back
watch your head hold your eyes god
out
come on come on come on out come on now
can you come on the back come out the
back
go out the
trunk got her you got it
here come here come on
come on
come on
come on come on come on
i got it come on
are you okay ma'am
ma'am are you okay
all right i'm gonna roll you on your
side okay
get this thing
hey man
come out get out help me help me get
them real quick come on
come
four four we got one now he's having a
seizure we need him
10 18.
we're not we're not gonna do anything
with it hey get everyone away from me
hey help me put him over there we'll get
away from the fire
one two three
here
you're okay okay buddy
[Applause]
come on brother
come on you do me
watch yourself
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i got his legs
let's go
thank y'all
oh
over here
just cut them off the hole
you okay
all right listen
you're not in trouble come out okay we
just hit a hole we're just here to help
you okay hello all right we're here to
help you okay
you live here we're just holding on to
you don't try to grab anything to hurt
yourself okay wanna take them off yeah
let's take them out
walk this way
come on we're just gonna we're just
gonna stay with you okay okay
yeah
hello
[Music]
do we have a ladder or anything
no i don't know that are they spraying
fire
uh
the kids are in here
fuck
get a ladder
[Music]
no i need a ladder
anybody got a ladder
is there a ladder
walt is in the room with her
tell him to come to the window
tomato 19. tom we need water in this for
this west window we got babies
give it to me
come here
give it to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no i need a medic
over here
[Music]
it says it's okay baby it's okay baby
it's okay baby it's okay
it's okay baby
[Music]
hey come here boss
come towards me you got a kid get out
there's a kid in here there's a kid in
here
come out here come out here
let's go
no no no no no no hey come here
[Music]
give me the baby
okay it's okay
get on out
live there's 16 i got the girl out
mail is now coming out as well
get on out boss
here it's okay
[Applause]
start working that door
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
baby
[Applause]
mom
bye
[Applause]
you're sweating pretty good aren't you
hi
you want to have the squad just checker
[Applause]
while we're here
she's a little hot
uh we should be all right for right now
we appreciate it thank you
hold on
hold on hold on
hold on hold on
out
come on guys
come here
okay i need your help
hey i need your help